what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
so picking up with infinity Wars part 5
again in this part we really kind of
pick up in in soul world now again these
guys are all fighting to vondre and and
again this is kind of a new introduction
here by Jerry Dugan and that's one of
the crazy things is a lot of stuff is
being changed here that's one of things
we talked about in previous videos is a
lot of things are being changed here so
world never looks like this now of
course we can basically attribute this
to the fact that Marvel the Marvel
Comics is now copying the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as opposed to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe copy Marvel
Comics but the overall gist here is that
with Diwan Dre is basically this entity
that exists to kind of go through and
consume everything inside of soul world
which is kind of strange because for
what we've gathered so far Gamora has
basically acquired the soul stones for
herself to kind of recreate the universe
but in order to do this order to get the
heroes out of the way she can find them
all to soul world and then accidentally
merge them all together in the in the
first place which kind of begs the
question why didn't she just wipe them
all out with the salt with the infinity
gems you know with with the Infinity
Gauntlet probably because we already saw
that hoes do that once and I guess you
can't do the same gag twice but
nonetheless while all that fight is
going on between the merged heroes in
and of Ondra you end up having Emma
Frost miss Marvel Kane the Conqueror
ant-man Scott Lang Loki and The
Incredible Hulk who were kind of off on
a mission of their own now we don't know
the specifics of this mission is just
one of the things where Emma Frost is
just kind of like hey we have to go to
this particular location now that's one
of the things to bear in mind here Jerry
Dugan does discover there's a lot of
hand waving in terms of like why things
are happening likewise Emma Frost go
into this location how do all these
things on Forbes its kind of well I mean
you know they are and that's just kind
of these kinda have to run with it but
the location they're traveling to is
basically where you have child Gamora
hanging out now again we don't know how
child Gamora got here from that from
what we're being said what were being
told here for what we've seen so far
that the older version of Gamora who was
confined to Soul world she was there
because in the the old-school comics
when you had um Adam warlock and pip the
troll and Gamora who operated as kind of
the early days of the Infinity watch
when they were confined within Soul
world Nick amor when she left had left a
piece of herself behind so it sort of
made sense that it worked that way and
it just kind of always been that way why
child Gamora is here we're not entirely
sure but the explanation is offered
almost immediately and that's kind of
the cool little bit here what we end up
finding out is that when Gamora
basically took all the various heroes
and put them inside Sol world that
included a portion of herself a piece of
herself
now again is one of the things were
Gamora didn't really seem
recognize it didn't really seem to
notice it and again a little bit of hand
waving going on here but one of the
things that we have is child Gomorrah
playing with a set of Infinity stones
now this is new this is really Jerry
Dugan just kind of cooking the books a
little bit and that's one of the things
to bear in mind again we've talked about
this in previous videos but when it
comes to the Infinity stones they only
work in their own universe and a
universe only ever has one set of
Infinity stones the Marvel Cinematic
Universe only has one set of Infinity
stones the main Marvel Universe only has
one set of Infinity stones the ultimate
universe all these different alternate
realities there's no universe that
exists in Marvel Comics where you have
more than one set of Infinity stones but
because of the fact a Kimura had
basically created kind of like a
duplicate so to speak of the main Marvel
Universe and then threw it all into soul
world that came with the Infinity stones
as well so she basically created new
stones using existing Infinity stones
it's not supposed to be able to happen
you know it's like wishing for more
wishes when it comes to a genie sure
it's a cool idea to have but at the end
of the day it's not something that can
actually be done from there Loki ends up
basically dispersing the Infinity stones
among the various members of the team of
what's really kind of like this
ramshackle infinity watch now it's kind
of interesting here because what Loki
says is these stones the Infinity stones
themselves aren't operating the way
they're normally supposed to and they're
kind of different from what we're used
to and so what he basically says is that
what we would normally expect emma frost
to get the mine stone because she's such
a high-level telepath or we would expect
the incredible hulk to get the power
stone because he's just raw infinite
strength instead Loki starts switching
things up it says actually Emma Stone is
or Emma Frost is gonna get a different
stone the incredible hulks gonna get it
you know get like the space stone
different things like that that it's all
gonna kind of shift up from the normal
status quo because each stone serves a
particular purpose and so what seems to
be going on here is Loki's hitting at
the idea that there there is basically
getting the stones because they're
serving a purpose as opposed to you know
something that inherently would allow
them to build on their own power which
again is kind of a part of the status
quo but it still works not only that
these stones because they basically
manipulate the universe basically allow
them to leave soul world now in truth
that's possible that's entirely possible
for example if you had the Infinity
stone the space stone you could use that
to enter Asgard if you wanted to that's
entirely possible as one of these bear
in mind guys is that what you have if
you if you were to imagine like a plate
for example you know just like it like a
dinner plate and on that plate you have
them that that plate is like the main
Marvel Universe then on that plate you
have like as guard and you've got
Olympus for the Greek gods dwell and
you've got the realm of Dormammu using
the space stone you can go anywhere in
that universe you can hop skip and jump
anywhere within the realm of that
universe to go from like one dimension
to another we've never really seen
anybody do that before because the
story's never called for it but it's
entirely possible and it's within the
possibility of those Infinity stones to
pull that off and that's the reason why
in this particular story while the
Infinity stones are using do originate
in Soul world the O soul world itself is
still part of the universe
so they're basically inside a dimension
inside the main Marvel Universe they can
just leave that dimension and go back
into the main Marvel Universe and that's
exactly what they do they immediately
enter into the realm of Gamora who's
basically hanging out at the quarry of
creation fighting you know Phi Lavelle
and and and moon dragon of course this
leads to the arrival of Emma Frost and
and so on and so forth all of whom's
start facing off against against Gamora
now under normal circumstances they
would never be able to stop her they
would never be able to defeat Gamora
because of the stones she wields but
because they have Infinity stones that
make them her equal then what this now
means is they can use them for her you
know they can begin literally go
toe-to-toe with her and ultimately come
out on top
now this is also a very important thing
to bear in mind here is that when it
comes to the Infinity stones just
because a person possesses them does not
mean they can use them to their full
potential that's one of the big
differences it's one of the things that
Thanos hit on during the original
gauntlet story up by jim Starlin Thanos
has been around for a long time for like
hundreds if not thousands of years he's
been around for a very very very long
hunt and he's acquired all kinds of
knowledge on a wide array of different
things it's so using his intelligence
when he accesses the Infinity Gauntlet
he can use it to its full potential
because he's so durable he could
withstand the extreme power it possesses
he won't go crazy by you know
manipulating reality using the reality
stone that was established here in the
events of Thanos quest when he first
gained the gauntlet in the first place
where he started going through and
tracking down the stones but then you
look at someone like Parker Robbins you
look at someone like xx stark you look
at members of the Infinity watch like
Hulk or somebody like that and they
can't really use the stone to its full
potential because in truth they're just
not smart enough they don't really have
the mental faculties to pull it off
someone like Reed Richards could do it
you know we've seen him wield the
Infinity Gauntlet but again you know for
someone like Gamora she is I mean she's
not dumb but she's certainly not on the
same level as like Thanos in terms of
intellect or the capability necessary to
handle the full-on might of the Infinity
Gauntlet so while she can do some
impressive things she's not using the
stones at like 100% she's using him
probably like 70 or 80 percent or
something like that as a result is that
she's able to hold her own but if this
was Thanos in this situation he would
have destroyed them all he would have
found a way to destroy Emma Frost and
all his living characters and they would
have been wiped out you know quick fast
and in a hurry so again gamora's
overpowered pretty readily and it's kind
of cool to see The Incredible Hulk with
a space stone literally just like
ripping her apart like just flying
basically and throwing her into
everything but the other half of this is
remember Loki's got a mission of his own
to basically capture you know to kind of
recreate malt-o-meal near at least gain
some version of me linear and gain his
own Infinity stones you know gain the
Infinity stones for himself and that's
what he does while everyone is facing
off against Gamora what Loki does is he
starts traveling around and basically
smashing the Infinity stones off of
people basically just like palming them
and tricking people into believing that
he's just kind of working on their side
he steals from Miss Marvel he steals
from Scott Lang does the same thing
became the Conqueror and Emma Frost
literally takes all their Infinity
stones and then teleports away and so
and then just kinda like okay well then
when the world's going on here not only
that when Loki gets to whatever this
dimension is that he's at you know
inside what seems to be this quarry of
creation it's lined with Infinity stones
there's a ton of Infinity stones there
so again the plot thickens we don't
really know exactly what it is is taking
place here you know this is kind of the
quarry of creation of like the
multiverse but we don't really know to
what extent all this is being beginning
to unfold not only that the stones
themselves are powerless inside the
quarry of creation so again this seems
to exist outside of the multiverse which
makes sense you know I don't know how
you really create the multiverse while
you're inside of it you kind of have to
be outside of it like to be on verse or
something along those lines and so it
was kind of a tail in here again things
are left pretty ambiguous we basically
end up picking up with like Drax a
destroyer with Arthur Douglas but this
is back when he was in his human form
now if those you guys who were not
familiar with this the character of Drax
the destroyer was a guy named Arthur
moon dragon is his biological daughter
named Heather the way this originally
played out in Marvel Comics was that
Thanos had launched an invasion against
earth and when he did he had come across
Drax a destroyer and destroy come across
Arthur and like destroyed his car in the
process and when that happened Arthur
was dead Heather was believed to have
been dead and of course the wife was
killed and what ended up going on here
is is we basically had Heather who was
taken away by the father of Pharaoh's
and then her telepathy was essentially
unlocked and she was trying to become
one of the more
most powerful telepaths in Marvel Comics
and then you ended up having Arthur
Douglas who is basically resurrected
from the dead by Chronos the god for I
guess one of the cosmic entities and in
turn was transformed into Drax the
destroyer and given the sole purpose of
basically tracking down Thanos and
destroying him this situation is not
unfold the same way they do crash into a
tree but when they do the tree is
grouped and that's when Arthur basically
begins to save things like I know this
tree I know this guy so he's basically
having flashbacks to his life as Drax
the destroyer so again this seems to
take place inside of soul world but it's
very very ambiguous there's a lot of
cloak-and-dagger going on here we don't
really know exactly what's taking place
it's very very far fetched just really
kind of out there and even a little bit
confusing but it is somewhat interesting
it's one of these stories where Jerry
dude is just kind of like things are
happening and like you'll have to read
the next issue to find out which is of
course the finale again it's kind of
crazy to see this whole this whole
scenario unfold is kind of wild to see
it all take place but let me know what
you guys think down in the comment
section without being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come as explained make
sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]